[Music]
good morning everybody at seven o'clock
today was the day suggested by us
officials as the earliest day for a
possible russian invasion of ukraine
hasn't happened yet but a confusing
picture from the country's border russia
in one breath claiming to turn troops
around and in the next releasing
pictures of new naval drills in the
black sea what on earth is going on
we'll ask the defense secretary ben
wallace very shortly we'll also hear
from the former british ambassador to
the u.s that's lord kim darrock and
we'll speak to ukraine's ambassador to
the uk friend of the show now isn't he
it's wednesday the 16th of february
military maneuvers russia claims some
troops are pulling back from ukraine's
border then releases these new pictures
of naval drills in the black sea
yesterday following this warning from
the u.s president
more than 150 000 troops encircling
ukraine and belarus and along ukraine's
border
an invasion remains distinctly possible
i'm in kiev as ukraine marks a day of
unity while nato defense secretaries
meet in brussels to discuss the crisis
a call for prince andrew to be stripped
of his duke of york title as he settles
the civil sex assault case with his
accuser virginia defray reports he's
paid her millions
i'm at windsor castle where prince
andrew has been holed up as his legal
team fought his case
i'm live at new covent garden market
where the cost of living crisis is set
to get worse with inflation forecast to
rise again
the new vaccines being trialled to
target the omicron variant as wales
offers jabs to children over five we'll
get reaction from the world health
organization at 7 45
an eerie reconstruction a lawyer's take
on what happened on the set of the movie
rust where a woman was shot as her
husband sues alec baldwin
downer on the slopes medal hope dave
riding fails to win gold for team gb in
beijing we'll have reaction from the
slopes where he lets his trade
also on the program for you this morning
i'm making the most of
what's been placed in front of me
these ones these small ones here right
now in the market they're going for
about
1500
speak to the real-life pet detective who
haunts the thieves snatching dogs off
the streets and selling them
and we'll speak to fitness expert diana
moran aka
the green goddess as research shows
exercise for over 70s can cut the risk
of heart disease
[Music]
very good morning everybody how you
doing this wednesday morning we start
with a warning from the u.s president
that there's still a distinct
possibility of a russian invasion of
ukraine despite russian military saying
they're pulling some troops back but
following president biden's remarks the
russian military has released some new
pictures of naval drills taking place
yesterday in the black sea so what on
earth is going on we'll ask the defense
secretary very shortly first mark stone
reports from the u.s
it certainly looked like a drawdown but
is it or are these images willingly
released by the russians or part of the
game brinkmanship for vladimir putin on
the border
in washington it prompted a statement
from president biden and a reality check
as the americans see it our analysts
indicate that they remain very much in a
threatening position
and the fact remains right now russia
has more than 150 000 troops encircling
ukraine and belarus and along ukraine's
border
an invasion remains distinctly possible
the president's life address was hastily
announced but delivered with a striking
directness
to the citizens of russia
you are not our enemy
and i do not believe you want a bloody
destructive war against ukraine
a country and a people with whom you
share such deep ties of family history
and culture
he was careful to span out that he
didn't seek to provoke
with so much at stake he and his
speechwriters needed this to be word
perfect world war ii
was a war of necessity but if russia
attacks ukraine it would be a war of
choice
or a war without cause or reason the
change in tone on the prospect of an
invasion was subtle no longer imminent a
distinct possibility
instead but the messaging was powerful
with that decision to address the
russian people directly
in moscow the german chancellor met
president putin who was no doubt
enjoying the attention of the latest
european leader to sit at the end of his
long table
but the russian president's red lines
seem immovable for now
it is
[Music]
the russians are ready 150 000 soldiers
half the air force an extraordinary
military movement some in washington had
suggested today would be putin's
invasion day but behind that jeopardy
they now say diplomacy could yet prevail
mark stone sky news in washington
i'm gonna be chatting to our defense
secretary very shortly but first let's
bring in the defense editor uh deborah
she's actually standing by and standing
by in kiev for us this morning hi
deborah very good morning to you a lot
of concerns about what might be
happening this morning doesn't seem any
sign thankfully of uh any russian troops
on ukrainian soil yet
well yeah if you wanted any reminder of
what's at stake for you just look behind
me this is the uh the memorial wall in
kiev of the of the soldiers the
ukrainian soldiers that have died so far
in eight years of conflict this is a
country that's been effectively in a
state of war ever since russia annexed
crimea back in 2014 and we've just
watched the european delegation here in
the capital coming to sort of pay their
respects with um with laying roses at
the memorial wall all part of this um
day of unity that was called by
president zorensky earlier in the week
when there really was that sense of
imminence being given by the uk and the
u.s of a possible attack naming today is
the date when a possible invasion
could start but like you said there's
been no sign of that yet you had those
words yesterday and images of russian
forces in some areas seemingly being
withdrawn
but in terms of what western officials
and analysts are saying they say yet on
balance there's no evidence of
de-escalation and the threat as joe
biden said is still distinctly possible
that an invasion could happen so still
very much alert today a day of unity
it'll be interesting to see um what sort
of scenes we have on the street and
whether people do rally to the
president's call to come out and show
their unity and defiance okay for now um
job i know you're going to update us
throughout the course of the morning but
for now thank you
i'm going to be bringing you the very
latest uh inflation figures in just a
moment or two but first the call today
for prince andrew to be stripped of his
dukedom after he settled his sex assault
case with virginia
charges that he has always denied is
believed the settlement runs to many
millions of pounds a joint letter
submitted to the u.s district court by
both legal teams said this prince andrew
intends to make a substantial donation
to mr frey's charity in support of
victims rights although of course we
don't know how much this is
prince andrew has never intended to
malign mr frey's character and he
accepts that she has suffered both as an
established victim of abuse and as a
result of unfair public attacks
prince andrew regrets his association
with epstein and commends the bravery of
mr frey and other survivors in standing
up for themselves and others
it goes on he pledges to demonstrate his
regret for his association with epstein
by supporting the fight against the
evils of sex trafficking and by
supporting its victims
among those who've commented on the
settlement is the labour mp for york
central rachel maskel she has said a
young woman trafficked and exploited she
bravely spoke out people of privileged
position and power tried to suppress and
silence this must be a turning point
where york is not a duke's title but a
people's movement to fight for the
rights of women and girls
let's bring in the defense secretary ben
wallace who's standing by for us from
brussels this morning hello to you
defense secretary thanks for joining us
so much to talk about as well as ukraine
is concerned but i wondered given that
you are a former military man whether
you just could offer a comment please if
you would about the fact that prince
andrew just talking about it there has
reached an out-of-court settlement over
these uh alleged uh sex scandals he is
of course
a falklands veteran um should we now
once again be um
or should he i should say be allowed to
represent his many regiments um
including the grenadier guards
well i think he represents uh any of
them at the moment okay i think the
palace took a decision that
those titles were to be removed from him
so i think he is effectively acting now
as
as a private citizen and so far as both
addressing the challenges and the and
the allegations and i think as you've
just reported on uh there's been a
obviously a payment and i think that is
where he currently remains the the
the decision on titles uh rests
obviously with the palace uh in the
future but i think it's been pretty
clear uh that this settlement is a
recognition that he wants to bring this
to a close and also recognize as his
statement says uh the
suffering and the challenges that the
victims have uh been through
as a result of their allegations and
their stand
against the exploitation by epstein
let's move on to what's happening as far
as ukraine is concerned you're in
brussels today nato headquarters boris
johnson said that there were mixed
signals coming out of russia yesterday
have they become any clearer today
well i think what we haven't seen is
evidence of withdrawal
that has been claimed by the kremlin
in fact we've seen continued build up of
things like field hospitals
and strategic weapons systems such as
iskandar missiles deployed so
i i think the reality is i said last
week when i visited moscow is that we'll
take russia at its word but we'll judge
them on their actions and you know if
we're going to build up true trust uh to
try and de-escalate this uh incident
what we need to make sure is that we're
not building up troops at the same time
and that is still what we see and until
we see a proper de-escalation i i think
we should all be cautious about the
direction of travel from the kremlin
i mean we have been told about naval
drills we've seen pictures actually of
those naval drill drills um in the black
sea at least those are pictures from
yesterday what is our latest
intelligence
well the latest intelligence is that
basically there's over 100 battalion
tactical groups of the russian ground
forces that 60 of the entire russian uh
gra land combat power on the borders of
ukraine 130 000 plus uh troops both in
belarus and indeed ukraine but also out
at sea there's effectively a significant
flotilla of russian amphibious landing
ships and indeed warships and missile
ships and you know from a ukrainian
point of view they're they're fairly
surrounded by a very large force of
ready troops and i think you know that
continues that that hasn't they haven't
taken the foot off the gas uh you know
readiness is one of the first signs you
always get about how serious a country
is
and if you wanted to inflict
intimidation on ukraine that deployment
is doing exactly that and i think that's
why we're all here at nato today and
tomorrow to try and work together to
reduce uh tensions and try and
de-escalate but you know it's a very
significant force it's a force that
would overwhelm ukraine should it be
deployed and i think that's why we need
to see clear de-escalation by the
removal of troops
at the same time as entering the
discussion with russia
we were warned um quite severely and
your boss the foreign secretary on the
program yesterday saying that we could
be at war today um and that brits needed
to get out urgently from ukraine
were we failed by us intelligence
look i've never talked about a date
because in all the intelligence i've
seen
that you know dates are not the issue
the issue here is
the significant amount of forces you
know
i've been a soldier when you go on
excise you don't set up huge amounts of
blood banks and hospitals in the field
you don't move strategic weapon systems
designed to protect other parts of
russia
onto the edges of ukraine so the real
indications here have not been a date
the real indications have been the
gradual and steady and significant
buildup of forces into a readiness
posture and indeed into a deployment
posture which we've seen in the last few
days that would uh significantly uh
indicate a incursion into ukraine forces
can only be held at readiness for so
long the russians are better at it than
most they could hold those forces at
readiness for weeks so there's really no
point speculating on a specific date uh
however the there are definitely dates
uh in the mix but i think it's unhelpful
to speculate because if you do you get
exactly the question you you've rightly
asked which is what if it what it wasn't
today has it all been wrong uh i can
tell you it hasn't been wrong i can also
tell you that you know
judge with your own eyes at the scale of
that russian deployment on the borders
of ukraine and indeed all the press
conferences by president putin it's
pretty clear uh that their intentions
towards ukraine are to change their
behavior and all deed change nato's
relationship with ukraine
and they're doing so at the threat of
invasion and i think that's something
that we as nato are here to challenge
and in order and also to deter
you say that troop placement that troop
deployment on the borders there at least
two borders um could overwhelm ukraine
if they moved uh into ukraine but the
foreign affairs select committee chair
tom tugginhall himself a military man
saying that 130 150 000 troops whatever
the number is um is nowhere near enough
to cause problems severe problems uh
with ukraine certainly not to occupy it
well there's a difference between
invading and holding uh a hundred and
you know 100 battalion tactical groups
hundreds of fighter aircraft uh warships
out at sea
the russians have overwhelming forces
over ukraine
and if they really wish to inflict
violence and invade they could do that
the ukrainians would put up a brave
resistance i made it very clear to the
russians the ukrainians will fight but
those odds are overwhelming
and no one should delude themselves that
they're not and and you know i'm a i
respect tom a lot but i'm afraid he's
wrong on the scale and the figures of
the military forces on either side of
the equation so what's your advice to
brits that are in ukraine um should they
be breathing a sigh of relief at the
moment or should they still be as
anxious as they were this time yesterday
i think they should follow the foreign
office advice which is you know we are
in a position where uh we don't think
president putin has made a final
decision which is again why we think
those forces are still poised at
readiness
and until that decision is made and
communicated by the kremlin i think the
citizens either dual nationals or
british citizens in ukraine should
continue to follow the well-considered
foreign office advice and uh seek to
either leave or avoid travel to ukraine
chancellor schultz um speaking uh after
he'd been to see president putin saying
that he doesn't think that ukraine
should be allowed to join nato we also
heard from um uh general richard dannet
who used to be in charge of the army as
you know he also said the same thing are
they both speaking out of turn
well i think
my understanding of what chancellor
schultz said was that
it wasn't uh you know nato ukraine's
succession to nato was not uh on the
agenda uh i mean
nate ukraine is on a path towards
joining nato but at a path that is
obviously a very long term path they are
currently an enhanced
partner to nato
but of course nato is fundamental policy
is an open door policy that we will
accept applications and consider as the
30 members anyone who wishes to choose
to join nato we do so in accordance with
our values that is a very important
principle of nato nato collectively
reaffirmed that including the germans
only recently in the response to the
russian government uh so that is the
german position it's the british
position and it's all 30 nations of nato
so it's exactly the same that we have an
open door policy uh and uh you know we
we engage with those countries that wish
to join us
uh i wonder if you could clarify words
are important of course you said in the
sunday times a whiff of munich it caused
quite a lot of upset at the time what
did you actually mean by that defense
secretary were you suggesting we're
heading to uh world war iii or we should
be concerned about appeasement
well no i think so okay what i said was
if ukraine was invaded there would be a
whiff of munich because in the munich uh
conference with adolf hitler in
the late 30s and there were two parts so
one was appeasement was effectively
where france and britain were very
worried in those days obviously about
the consequence of a further war having
suffered through the first world war and
that is a you know a long uh
covered historical event but the other
part of the munich was the clear
deception by adolf hitler he had a plan
already to expand way beyond uh you know
the parts of the czech republic he was
after it was effectively a deception and
while everyone was running after the
straw man
off this argument about just give me a
little bit of border dispute resolution
he was planning a completely different
agenda and i've been very consistent on
president putin that i have felt that
part of the argument about being
encircled by nato is in fact a straw man
i wrote an article a few weeks ago about
that and the danger is we all coalesce
around this argument while all along if
he invades nato uh invade sorry ukraine
it would have been a clear sign that he
had a plan all along and you know what
we're seeing at the moment is a clear
plan i mean he has massed thousands of
forces on another country's borders
and that doesn't quite look like uh the
the fears he has about nato given that
ukraine is not in nato uh it looks like
a similarity so that was what i was
trying to say i did say uh i think some
of the media took a different angle on
it okay we must let you go defense
secretary i know it's a very busy time
for you thank you very much indeed for
spreading the time to join us on skype
thank you thank you thank you thank you
uh breaking news uh as far as inflation
is concerned it's jumped to a new
30-year high my goodness me what's that
going to mean for all of you at home
this morning let's find out helen ann is
standing by for us this morning hi helen
and tell us more
good morning kay yeah really more bad
news for consumers for families at home
who need to pay their bills for
businesses as well at the cost of
everything continuing to go up so the 12
months uh to january inflation went up
by 5.5 percent put that into some
context that's the highest in 30 years
the bank of england they like to keep
their inflation around two percent uh so
really a census is pushing up very
quickly indeed and unfortunately it
probably doesn't end here okay
predictions are uh that inflation will
continue to go up for the next few
months potentially even to as much as
seven percent a little bit later in the
spring i'm at new covent garden market
in london this is the biggest uh
wholesale market in the uk if you've
eaten out particularly if you've eaten
out in london your food probably came
from here and i'm at nature's choice
this is one of the traders here uh
interestingly the boss of this trading
unit said to me that his prices the
inflation that he's seeing on the fresh
food that he
buys and sells on is up at 16 so
food really one of the key drivers to
this inflation we know there's other
things going on we know the cost of
energy is a big contributor here housing
costs of well have been a big one this
month so really really concerning for
lots of families
across the uk and as i said fears that
it will continue to go up in the coming
months as well okay helena thank you
30-year high for inflation let's bring
in the managing director of iceland
foods uh richard walker hello to you mr
walker thank you for joining us on the
program um what does that mean for your
customers do you think already really
stretched
yeah absolutely we are starting to see a
lot of inflation through the supply
chain um and it's everywhere from labor
shortages uh through to commodity prices
through to fuel prices and obviously
heating which we all know about and that
is starting to have an impact uh on
shelf um and the the latest inflation
figures were around 5.4 percent um but
of course for the hardest press families
it which you know some some of some of
whom we serve
it can be significantly more than that
as they struggle to make ends meet so it
is serious and as a business we need to
do absolutely everything we can to keep
prices as competitive as possible which
is why we have a number of different
schemes that we're we're launching
and your business model of course is
based on frozen food i'm guessing that
you are badly hit by energy price
increases as well
yeah we do use a lot of energy um 100 of
that is is renewable so
at least it's green energy but uh
absolutely and for business there's no
consumer price cap
so you know we just have to stomach the
wholesale uh prices on the market um but
look we've been in business for 51 years
we worked day and night to
be as absolutely as competitive as as
possible
and therefore we we do everything we can
to to make sure um that would that we
provide you know good value for our
consumers now you can do that through
frozen food anyway because it's a good
way of saving money and making food go
further reducing food waste but we've
also committed to to freezing all of the
the one pound uh lines uh in our stores
in the frozen section for the rest of
the year and that's obviously to help
customers um through through this tricky
time
and tell us more about this uh nhs
healthy start scheme
more on that if you would please
yeah something else we did through the
pandemic was um to to
try and promote and support this scheme
uh was to give away free vegetables to
anyone with an nhs voucher what what we
found is that there was very little
awareness and therefore take up of the
healthy start scheme and now nhs healthy
start and best start as it's known in
scotland and help those who are pregnant
or have responsibility for
very young
kids and are on
low incomes and it gives them some money
each week in in these vouchers it's
just over four pound for for pregnant
women eight pound fifty per week for um
uh kids under one and four pound twenty
five for one to four year olds and they
can buy um uh fresh frozen or tin fruit
and veg they convey uh by playing cow's
milk infant formula fresh tin pulses so
what we're doing uh is putting this on
all of our milk bottles to raise
awareness of the scheme because we're
calling on the food industry to really
get behind this this is uh government
money that is set aside and uh is you
know people are eligible for it uh we
think 130 000 people are not taking up
this scheme that are eligible it's it's
free money that they can buy healthy
food with which obviously leads to many
different benefits so if we put it on
our milk
that will get it um on 80 000 products
uh um
throughout the uk and
actually a further nine
sorry 80 million uh units through
through uh england
wales and northern ireland and a further
nine million in scotland so it will
really sort of bring the scheme alive
we're also going to support it with
window posters and some in-store
activities and we've also put qr codes
uh of the scheme on some of our delivery
vans and that in turn will be seen by uh
thousands of people as well okay um so
we really think this will help um
hundreds of thousands of families but
also it should untap tens of millions
of spends that people
can uh can buy healthy foods with
okay amazing work thanks very much for
taking the time to tell us more about it
thank you thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning joined
on the sofa by ukraine's ambassador to
the uk he'll be here very shortly after
nine o'clock
also the green goddess she's going to be
joining me to talk about why the over
70s are being encouraged to get moving
and also celebrity hairdresser larry
king about a campaign to celebrate the
nation's hairdressers
before that let's return to one of our
other main stories and there's a call
today for prince andrew to be stripped
of his dukedom after he settled his sex
assault case with virginia dufrey
charges that he has always denied it's
believed the settlement runs to millions
of pounds madeleine ratcliffe is in
windsor for us this morning i think it's
your first time on the show isn't it
madeline very good morning to you what's
happening there
good morning kay yes so the legal cloud
may have lifted from prince andrew the
court cases behind him but there are
really significant questions and and the
main one of that is
how it is how is he paying for this the
telegraph reports that the settlement
could be worth as much as 12 million
pounds to michoud frey and her victims
charity
certainly many millions of pounds and
where has the money come from that if if
it has come from the queen if she is
effectively paying this settlement for
andrew that will certainly be
controversial and and it leads to
further questions about prince andrew's
role in public life going forward should
he keep his dukedom for example there
have been calls for him to give up the
title the duke of york and in this
platinum jubilee year celebrating the
queen's queen's jubilee how much of a
role a public-facing role will he want
to take with the family in the summer so
the
the case is behind him but certainly
questions remain over over the royal
family
okay good to talk to you thank you
also making news for you this morning
wales has become the first country in
the uk to announce it will offer the
covet vaccine to all five to 11 year
olds the welsh health minister said the
decision was made after officials were
given access into a still unpublished
study by the joint committee on
vaccination and immunisation
there have been another 46
186 cases recorded in the last 24 hours
a further 234 people have died which
takes the total number of people who
have died within 28 days of a positive
coveted test to 160 000 almost
and more on jobs for children and a new
vaccine trial later this hour when we
speak to the who's special envoy for
covid19 that's david nabarro
a six-year-old girl who has been missing
for two years has been found under a
staircase in new york
paisley schultes was allegedly abducted
by her biological parents after they
lost custody in 2019. police said she
appeared to be in good health a woman
and two men have been arrested
and charged
the lancet and world psychiatric
association commission says half of the
people with depression in high income
countries such as the uk go undiagnosed
or untreated the figure rises to eight
to ninety percent in low and middle
income countries and researchers say
that now a whole of society response is
needed to tackle the issue
i think for me the most important
message is to destigmatize depression as
a very common health condition that
affects a very large proportion of the
population but remains sadly poorly
recognized and very misunderstood
the husband of halnia hutchins who was
killed during the filming of rost has
filed a lawsuit for wrongful death
against the actor alec baldwin which
includes a reconstruction of events on
set the cinematographer was shot dead in
october last year while filming the
western in new mexico a family lawyer
confirmed legal papers have now been
filed in the state's santa fe county
detailed animated video that recreates
the shooting was also revealed it shows
alec baldwin and the crew all on set in
the moments before ms hutchins death a
lawyer for mr baldwin and the other
producers of ross said they continued to
cooperate with authorities and denied
any suggestion of negligence
players of wordle were left frustrated
yesterday after there were two possible
answers depending on the platform being
used if users played on the original
site the answer was agora but for those
on the new york times version the
correct choice was aroma
a bit confusing isn't it but there we go
however wordle has also made the
headlines for the right reasons in the
last few days as it was responsible for
an eight-year-old woman in chicago being
rescued from a hostage situation she had
been held for 21 hours
by a man with scissors and officers only
knew to check on her after she failed to
text one of her daughters her daily
wordle score there you go
more disappointment for team gb at the
winter olympics medal hopeful dave
riding has missed out in the slalom
final finishing 13th
let's find out more from fraser should
we standing by a pendle ski club for us
hi fraser good morning
good morning kate it's a bit blustery
here on the ski sloping pendle at the
moment the view is just about opening up
i'm told that you can see blackpool
tower on a good day not today you can't
but we can see people out on the slopes
already getting warmed up disappointed
of course that dave ryding couldn't get
into those medal places particularly
after he did so well in kittspool in the
world cup competition just about a month
ago first gb skier to win an alpine
world cup event but we can get reaction
now from amy fuller double olympian
herself in snowboarding slopestyle
disappointing but
he did so well didn't he to get there
yeah of course super disappointing but i
think if you were to look at dave's
career as a whole four-time olympian and
just seeing the magnitude and the impact
his career has had on this next
generation that clubhouse was full of
kids aged six to twelve and now they're
out here it's half seven and everyone's
getting after it so what was it that
first got you into into snowboarding was
it seeing people like dave seeing your
heroes when you were you know when you
were just a toddler and encouraging you
to get out on the slope yeah for me i
always remember watching the x games and
the olympics on television and just
thinking
that would be so cool but it was such a
distant dream
it's one of those things that you think
oh i could never do that but the truth
is if you can see it you can be it and
that's the impact dave has had on these
kids today i mean he's a total hero
appears the four olympics and it is such
a bruising sport isn't it you've got
more than your fair share of broken
bones to attest to that i have i've
fractured my eye socket it's broken my
coccyx but
that's a small price to pay for the
lifetime of opportunity i've had to live
my dream and i think let's say maybe
snowboarding is a little bit more
dangerous in terms of the big tricks
but just seeing
these kids out here today has made me
smile even though i got up at half four
this morning fantastic i'm smiling too
it's blowing a gale up here at the
moment storm dudley's on his way but
it's not stopping people getting out
here on the slopes the next generation
it's starting right here in pendle okay
can you tell that gorgeous lady she
looks amazing but half four is a lion
for me
i will indeed kay says that you look
absolutely amazing considering you got
up at half four thank you kay
love that dialing it out in your amazing
coat i'm loving it loving it okay thank
you thanks a lot
the hairdresser not quite what i said is
it now talk about keeping it in the
family take a look at this
there you go it's at mac rutherford at
only 16 years old he's hoping to become
the youngest person ever to
circumnavigate the world alone in a
microlight which is a sort of
lightweight
aircraft
if he's successful in his attempt he'll
set a new world record and guess who
he'll take that world record from
his 19 year old sister zara who
completed the challenge last month mack
is due for takeoff on the 17th of march
both of the kids flying around the world
maybe they don't like their mum's
cooking i don't know our top stories for
you this morning president biden has
called on vladimir putin to halt
aggressions towards ukraine saying the
u.s has not yet verified russian claims
it has started withdrawing some troops
from the border
caused prince andrew to be stripped of
his jupiter after he settled his sex
assault cases with virginia dufres
charges he denies it's believed the
settlement runs to millions
inflation rises at its fastest annual
rate in nearly 30 years jumping to 5.5
last month as households feel the
squeeze from risingville
no
in the last half an hour defense
secretary ben wallace told me russia
should be judged by its actions when it
comes to de-escalating tension at the
ukraine border saying there's no
evidence of a troop withdrawal
they haven't taken the foot off the gas
you know readiness is one of the first
signs you always get about how serious a
country is
and if you wanted to inflict
intimidation on ukraine that deployment
is doing exactly that it's a very
significant force it's a force that
would overwhelm ukraine should it be
deployed and i think that's why we need
to see
clear de-escalation by the removal of
troops
tamara's here what do you make what do
you have to say this morning morning
morning k well as ben wallace heads to
nato defense ministers meeting nato's
position is very clear this is the most
serious security crisis europe has faced
in decades and despite the mixed
messages over the last couple of days
the pictures of the russian tanks
withdrawing this it remains
potentially very imminent the threat of
invasion ben wallace was saying that the
number of troops we believe has massed
on the ukraine border joe biden put it
at 150 000 he said about 140 000 he said
that is enough to overwhelm ukraine he
said that it was wrong to suggest that
this is only enough for a quick strike
and then not to hold it and he said that
that is very much the basis that they
are planning on when they think about
what deployments they're going to send
to ukraine's neighbours to shore them up
in the event of an invasion tomorrow's
take nine o'clock see then i'm looking
forward to it thanks very much indeed
joined now by the former german
ambassador to moscow that's rudiger
von fritch hello to thank you very much
indeed for joining us mr ambassador what
is your view on what mr putin is up to
at the moment
well good morning and thank you for
inviting me um
the threat to ukraine still is there but
it's beyond the threat to ukraine an
overall threat to the european peace
order
a fundamental change the russian
leadership is up to trying to overcome
what we have jointly agreed agreed upon
partly decades ago and what has secured
peace in europe so this threat is still
there all his demands are on the table
no nato extension bearing our central
eastern european partners from nato
defense capabilities withdrawing the
american nuclear umbrella from europe
which is the sort of heart piece of our
security this is still all on the table
but looking back at the stretch over the
last let's say eight weeks we see that
diplomacy has
made progress and that is due to the
united stand of western leaders and i
think it was clearly demonstrated
yesterday by chancellor schultz's visit
to europe there is clear messaging
if russia chooses to unleash war there
will be a massive response and will
damage fundamentally the interest also
of the russian leadership and russia's
economic and financial interests but we
are already trying to overcome the
dialogue the
ongoing conflict in dialogue and that's
a situation we are in maybe if we can
verify that russia is actually
withdrawing at least part of its troop
we could say we are one step back from
the abyss of war
we know that um your leader went to see
president putin yesterday in moscow you
know uh how president putin
operates um
when can you tell whether he's bluffing
well you should judge him by the facts
you should judge him by what's actually
happening but also by the messaging done
and that messaging was more positive
than we've seen over the last few weeks
there was a readiness he said there are
proposals by the west replying to his
answer which are interesting which we
should discuss and that could be a basis
that we could try to build on we can
continue the so-called normandy format
with france and germany moderating a
process the only one where russia and
ukraine directly
can meet and exchange their difficulties
and views he's ready to continue that
there is substance being brought in by
ukraine now russia should bring in
substance so we can slowly try to make
some progress discuss other issues
transparency measures confident security
building measures discuss arms control
but the huge issues behind it which are
in russia's interest migration pandemia
you name it and
that can lead us into a process where we
can build new security arrangements
which should not give up the basic
principles which we must stick to
because it guarantees our security and
part of this is the independent
sovereignty of countries like not only
ukraine but also let's say finland or
sweden to decide about their own
security
interesting you uh mentioned sweden
russia's ambassador to sweden one of
your peers
says that moscow doesn't give a damn
about the threat of western sanctions do
you agree with him
well they have to say that of course
they will always say will not affect us
but what we have lined up and russia
clearly knows about it would very
severely affect not only the overall
interests of russia but
the revenues of its leadership which it
urgently needs in order to keep up
the support of the people in the country
which is not guaranteed and let's for
example say the russian leadership would
unleash a war in ukraine it's not given
that would be supported by the people in
the country particularly if it would
there would be dramatic losses and costs
etc and part of the cost is a complete
um disalignment from from the west and
other therefore they do need this and
they have realized that we are united
and that we are resolved to react whilst
at the same time trying to overcome this
dialogue so i think they have to say
sanctions will not affect us but they
would definitely
good to talk to you thank you for
joining us on the program my pleasure
thank you so much
weeks now people in ukraine have been
living with a constant threat of wars
we've been hearing throughout the show
in the city of kharkiv people are
preparing for an invasion our chief
correspondent stuart ramsey reports from
there
she's searching for airaid shelters
theoretically they're dotted throughout
the eastern ukrainian city of kharkiv a
website identifies the basements of
buildings designated by the government
as suitable bunkers if the city comes
under attack
if it does happen everyone is directed
to these shelters there are said to be
four thousand three hundred of them but
yulia smayner has only been able to find
100 so far and of them 94 were
uninhabitable or more commonly locked
with tensions rising here the lack of
preparedness is becoming a big issue for
the government
so it seems this shelter
it appears at least that this shelter
was actually up to its knees in water
the ladies saying that um
we were just getting direction they
start there obviously it's quite a big
issue they're pretty angry about this
because the one place that they know
they would at least be able to protect
themselves from the russian missiles is
you know impossible they're either
locked or in this case it's full of
water
downstairs is genuinely awful the stench
of human waste is overpowering it is
impossible to imagine anyone taking
refuge here
julia will report her latest findings to
the authorities
like many she's got used to the threats
coming from russia and like many she
believes one day russia will invade
do you think the russians will invade i
think
today now
and tomorrow now but
in the future in future maybe maybe in
future because
they want us
to
break
yeah
two times a week every week eleanor's
that cover and her daughter daria meet
in their kitchen running through safety
protocols they've developed if car keefe
is attacked
they have an emergency escape bag with
some medicines and passports permanently
ready to go
elena escaped the separatist city of
luhansk taken over in 2014.
she's praying it doesn't happen again
um
despite the dire warnings about an
invasion and huge casualties here
there's no discernible sense of panic
people are worried of course but
nothing's really changed
mr ramsey sky news car keith
when he calls to prince andrew to lose
his duke of york title after agreeing to
settle the civil sexual assault case
against him for what is reported being
millions of pounds we don't know how
many millions legal commentator joshua
rosenberg is with us now i don't suppose
you know do you joshua i don't know but
the daily telegraph says it's 12 million
pounds and that seems to be slightly
higher than the other papers are saying
it's clearly a large sum of money
uh it most certainly is uh why now
why now because the uh perhaps the fact
that uh prince andrew was due to be
questioned by lawyers for virginia
giffrey in london next month has
concentrated people's minds
of course we have the
celebrations of the
queen's platinum jubilee in the summer
and before that we have a service of
thanksgiving
for prince andrews late father and i
suppose the royal family didn't want
either of these events to be
overshadowed by the prospect of a civil
hearing which was planned for the autumn
what next what happens now
there's 30 days in which he has to come
up with the cash and pay it over and
then the case will be formally
discontinued he's also promised that he
will make a contribution to virginia
jeffrey's charity
will any more information come out
though that's i think the question that
people are interested in there's already
been some briefing of the newspapers as
far as i can see
the two sides have very clearly said
that they are not going to be talking on
the record
we don't know whether virginia giffrey
has signed a non-disclosure agreement
there's some speculation today that it
may be a temporary agreement
and it may allow her to tell her story
and perhaps write a book later this year
perhaps at the end of this year we don't
know any of that
but it does seem that the the royal
family presumably by helping prince
andrew to pay this settlement have
avoided this hugely damaging publicity
over the coming months
what happens if he doesn't pay on time
if he doesn't pay on time the judge has
said in terms well this case will come
back on and everybody will have to
cooperate with the uh timetable set by
the court although as you can see if the
parties uh go back to an agreement the
case stops and and so there won't be a a
hearing but yes he has to come up with
the money presumably he is
able to do that or he wouldn't have
agreed to this and the advantage of
agreeing to a settlement now is that
however much it costs he knows how much
it is it's a finite sum he presumably
has made arrangements to obtain this sum
and pay it whereas if it were to go to
trial in the autumn the cost would be
not only huge but uh unpredictably large
um so this is that's it dom this is uh
once the money's been uh paid over
that's the end of that but he there is
still an fbi case isn't there um pending
there is and investigators are going to
look at this settlement notice that
virginia jeffrey has
decided not to proceed with her civil
claim
so there'll be no evidence on the record
in a court in new york
that may affect how they look at it
there has also the possibility that if
they are going to go after associates of
jeffrey epstein and uh it's worth noting
that uh prince andrew in the statement
that was released yesterday uh admits
his association with epstein and
regretsa's association you would have
thought that fbi investigators would go
for people in the united states who
would presumably
be easier to interview and perhaps
easier to prosecute
good to talk to you as always thanks for
picking that for us much appreciated
let's talk about kovid should we around
3 000 volunteers in the uk are to
participate in a trial for a moderna
booster which specifically targets the
omicron variant of covid
19.
let's bring in dr david nabara should we
special envoy for the world health
organization um it's always great to see
doctor thank you what does madonna do
the other vaccines potentially don't
what we have now is a possibility of a
vaccine that is specially engineered
to be able to deal with the omicron
variant and that in turn
should lead to even greater protection
against it and against other variants
that are related to it
this is all good news okay what i wanted
to stress today
is how important it is that we continue
being active on two different fronts
here the first is to keep the
vaccinations going because they do
protect people from getting severely ill
and dying when they are affected by
these viruses there's some suggestion
that they vaccines will also give some
protection against long covered but i
also want to urge everyone to remember
this is still a dangerous virus we know
how to prevent spread so if we can
continue with our face masks with our
physical distancing and most of all with
respect for the virus that would be
really helpful we want to keep the
levels of virus down at the same time as
keeping the hospitals not overloaded
with cases and that's the strategy
inoculating five-year-olds in wales um
against covert 19 is that something that
should be rolled out further
well there's going to be constant
questions about how many uh uh how low
an age group you go to when you're
vaccinating children on the one hand
it's highly desirable to protect them on
the other hand there's constant question
as to whether or not there is the level
of risk in children that there is in
older people my own view is now that we
know that vaccines can give some
protection against long covid there is a
growing case for immunizing children and
so i i think that from my point of view
uh this is uh the direction to go in
um i'm just reading that the world
health organization's regional director
for europe
this was at the beginning of the month
on the 3rd of february saying that 30 of
all covey cases since the pandemic
began have been reported this year alone
and the european region recorded 12
million new cases in a week should we
really be in a position where we are
loosening off um
what we've put in place to try to
protect ourselves from kobe given you
know a third of cases of this year alone
well first of all it is
people who are going to deal with this
pandemic the virus is the problem and
people are the solution and more and
more now as i talk to even quite large
groups of people i realize that they are
making up their own minds as to how to
get on top of things and it is
absolutely not a good idea when cases
are as high as they are when the virus
is moving as rapidly as it is for the
restrictions that we've all applied so
carefully to be dropped please continue
wearing face masks continue physical
distancing it's the right thing to do
and whatever else you hear from other
sources i can assure you the world
health organization asks everyone to
maintain the caution because the virus
is really moving around a lot at the
moment and you do not want to let go of
the restrictions and to give the varus a
free ticket right now it's not the right
thing to do so yes kate you are right
maintain
personal precautions for the time being
there's too much virus around to let go
um two of the uh restrictions that
are most impactful on people's everyday
lives lockdowns and travel bans are they
effective
well you know that in the world health
organization we say very clearly
lockdown's a last resort they really are
they're very crude basically you're
stopping everybody from moving and
you're requiring them to stay at home
instead we say
protect against this virus with good
quality surveillance and local responses
organized by district or similar public
health officials and we will continue
with that advice and we will very much
say
do lockdowns only when you absolutely
have to you've got nothing else to do in
the same way we're cautious about
mandates requiring people to get
vaccinated or else they lose their jobs
because we think they create divisions
in society and they we would much rather
say to everybody you're part of the
solution we're not going to give you
these very tough mandates but we are
going to ask you to work together to
work with authorities because we can
only deal with this virus by working
together
good to talk to you as always uh we hope
that the family is very well loved to
all of them thank you doctor
thank you very much indeed but greetings
to everybody
andy thank you quick look at the weather
for you
[Music]
forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
today sees storm dudley we really need
somebody with a birmingham accent to say
that don't we bring a potentially
damaging winds to the north later before
storm eunice don't know who would say
that arrives on friday a met office
amber wind warning covers southern
scotland northern england and parts of
northern ireland from late afternoon
until midnight 70 mile an hour gusts are
possible there higher on coasts and
hills the irish met service has a
similar warning for donegal so be
careful if you're going out
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
this is what happened even before we see
storm dudley the sun carrying a picture
of a 300 foot wind turbine knocked over
the 20 million pound machine had been
hit by 50 not 50 mile an hour winds as
as i said storm dudley heading our way
this is uh what it did actually it's
already hit
in wales and that's what happened it's
one of the 10 wind turbines in the area
residents have called for an
investigation into the others to see
what's going on at the time there's a
picture from the annual jay sarma desert
festival in rajasthan in india it shows
officers from the country's border
security force parading
and very colorful they look too and
those camels look very happy with
themselves
and taking pampered pooch to a new level
the queen has launched a luxury perfume
for dogs the happy hounds dog cologne is
said to have smells of coastal walks
there you go corgis cologne
there we are no i don't know what to
make of that now how do you rescue a
sloth when it gets stuck up an
electrical pole
well
with um a broom of course there you go
come and get on this yep now just let go
of there and get hold of this and all
will be well come on little chap
coaxing him down these are the pictures
from terraza in colombia 20-minute
rescue there coming up in just a few
moments time what does the defense
secretary think will happen next in
ukraine find out in just a moment
you